what you're about to watch is a clip
from my brand Linux training where I get
together with entrepreneurs thought
leaders who want to build their brand
using YouTube and making data driven
decisions to blow up their Brand This
Year enjoy
welcome everybody uh so this month we're
doing a a topic breakdown and the theme
was importance of editing slash high
quality video and b-roll Etc that was uh
posted by Andrew so that's we're gonna
have a quick discussion on here and I
thought I'd pull up some channels and
talk about it too the key thing that we
want to think about here
all that matters in terms of editing and
b-roll is attention are you keeping
people's attention so the two things
that we need to focus on is can we get
people to click on our video
and clicking on the video is a function
of what do we calling it what's the
title what's the thumbnail so that we're
showing up and then people it's an
attractive thing that I want to click on
and go see
once they're on the video then it's
about retention are you keeping people
how much are people sticking around and
watching a video and this is where
editing slash b-roll slash whatever else
goes into production of the video
matters what I found over and over and
over again is inside education
the b-roll especially if we address that
first like b-roll almost doesn't matter
you can
and we have some on ours but it's not a
it's not a big deal like why are people
coming to watch your video they're
coming to learn
you know if I mean Andrew specifically
if Andrew who's doing Fitness videos or
recipe videos if you're going to be
showing off uh b-roll of the the food
or your biceps or you know whatever the
thing is cool but if it's b-roll of
somebody else like just some guy working
out in the gym then it's probably not
going to have a big impact and for the
most part it takes a lot of time to do
unless you're hiring an editor which you
could
but I'm here for education so what are
people here to watch they're here to
watch education just like when you're
going to watch a movie you're going to
go watch it for different reasons you're
going to watch it for a laugh you're
going to watch it for uh the special
effects like there are some movies that
you don't really care that much about
the plot or the drama because these
special effects are just so epic and
you're going for that's why you're going
you have to go watch it on the IMAX to
see the crazy special effects so inside
thought leadership
why are people coming they're coming for
the education they're coming for the
learning right uh so that's my quick
thoughts on B1 we can dive in deeper if
you want to maybe be real of yourself
doing something but for me it's always
cost benefit you know if that has a tiny
tiny like if it's a one percent
Improvement versus you spending more
time on the education or you making an
extra long-form video it's it's not even
close like go make the video
um I was talking to somebody who's a
movie makers and she spends you know a
couple out in her in her videos she
spends a couple hours
um planning and filming the videos and
then four hours editing the videos
it's like it's just not a good use of
time unless you unless you love editing
and you want to learn how to be an
editor
spending four hours editing a video is
just not a good use of time
what's better is to train yourself to be
a better speaker
and that first minute really really
matters most of you are probably good
once you're in the video at holding
attention
so if you're doing an interview you know
if Lydia's doing an interview with
somebody or Andrew's going through his
workout routine
or sharing something on your iPad or
whatever like once you're into the
content you're probably pretty good at
doing it it's the first minute that
really really matters and we default to
thinking about like b-roll and such
um in thought leadership it has almost
no impact
uh Dana says what about a splashy intro
video as long as it contributes so the
intro really matters
think about somebody's experience so
they're trying to learn how to write a
book right in Dan's case I want to I
want to learn how to write a book I want
to write my book in a Flash I've got a
message in me I want to get it out there
the scroll mindset is definitely there
at the beginning because I'm trying to
justify why should I spend time on this
video instead of somebody else's video
and I'm making a judgment call in the
first 30 seconds as to do I want to keep
watching this video or not
we've tested so many different things
and we still test and it's probably one
of the most frustrating things that I go
over with my team
um especially Ivan who's been with me
for so many years is like okay but we've
tried that before we've tried that
there's like there's not stuff that does
struggling to find new things to try and
whether it's our own ideas or you know
we're modeling a Mr Beast video or
something else
um
we've tried theatrical intros with crazy
music and motivation we've tried showing
words on the screen and flashing it in
we've tried like massive Super Cuts so
like boom boom boom boom boom boom boom
boom and the thing that still has the
biggest impact that we cannot beat is
just going right in
with a powerful opinion
in education
because I am watching your video why I'm
not watching your video for
uh entertainment I mean maybe you guys
are really funny I'm not
you're not coming and watching me for my
jokes
[Laughter]
learn you're coming to learn you're
coming to get to to get better so if
somebody's in that education mindset you
have to lead with with teaching me
something that I don't believe
so
what do you believe that I don't believe
and you could add some visuals and think
of anybody here you know Andrew's
probably the most visual person
right because if he's talking about how
to get killer biceps I want to if I'm
coming on the video say here's how to
get killer biceps and I'm not showing
off the killer biceps it's like who's
this guy who's to tell me about a
workout routine where everybody else
here I think is more just about like
what's in your mind
right if Dan's gonna teach me about how
to write a book I can't I can't make a
judgment call like what's the set gonna
be maybe there's a ton of books behind
him it doesn't really matter though like
I'm trying to get the sense of what's in
his brain for all of you like how how do
I know if Phil's a good lawyer or not is
there a lawyer of the Year award that he
can hang on his what you know like I
don't know I can't make a judgment call
until I hear you speak for most of you
so
then the most important thing that hook
attention is to hear you speak
so what are you going to share with me
that's going to make me stop the scroll
so if I want to if I want to write a
book I'm going through videos I see
Dan's okay I'm giving people like 10
seconds 15 seconds 4 seconds 30 seconds
I'm scrolling through videos before I
decide to go and watch that 20 minute
video and so you've got to capture my
attention in that first
30 seconds to minute
and if you can and keep them then
they're much more likely to stick for
the whole video and then having b-roll
and stuff in the middle of that video
has little to no impact
because it's an education
Evan yeah hey Pablo
um sorry guys I'm in in the God but if
one time you mentioned that um one of
the things that it can be good is when
we use two cameras and you show one of
your videos
you can this is like incremental
improvements
so if you have a second camera or a
higher quality camera it's incremental
improvements
um but I would always default to making
more videos than production quality of
videos quality of thought really really
matters
quality of thought is the most important
thing because you're a thought leader
because the thought leadership kind of
video so quality of thought really
matters production quality is not what
they're coming to your channel for
so if you're already at Maxi pass in
terms of making bit if you're making
daily videos already then we can start
worrying about
production quality
otherwise like I'm I'm here I'm I'm
selling my place where I bought a new
home I'm selling my place
so it's being staged right now Lydia
says I like the colors but this is not
my usual kind of vibe and environment
um but whatever I can make videos from
here
it's not going to make a big difference
you know it would not impact my
retention
um as long as it doesn't impact how I
show up because if I show up and I'm
insecure and I feel like oh my gosh why
am I this is not my usual microphone you
know it's not my anything that you know
does it matter for you guys you know no
I was like that's it I'm dropping out of
analytics I haven't changed his
background he's not in this fancy
microphone
I'm out screw this guy right no because
you're not here because of my background
or the microphone I use you're here
because hopefully I've got something
that I can teach you from all the stuff
that I've I've learned and tested so
that's all like minor minor minor
improvements if I'm learning if you're
going to teaching Pablo how to negotiate
then all I care is that I'm going to
learn how to negotiate
and having a second camera again go
Prove It Go prove it wrong
you know it's not that you can't do it
they're just usual it's usually minimal
improvements for most thought leaders
and the amount of effort goes through
the roof
the amount of effort to then especially
if you're doing it yourself
right if you had a team or somebody
coming in and filming you cool then that
let them do their thing if it's you now
having to set up two cameras and then go
find b-roll and then edit that all
together then that usually that that
um
that equation doesn't work out
and the better solution is spend all
that time you're researching cameras and
setting it up and adding b-roll spend
that time to make a third video or a
second video or fourth video
or spend the time being a better speaker
training yourself to not need editing
so that the first minute is punching
because if you spend for my movement
Maker's friend who spent four hours
editing the video if she spent four
hours practicing the speech or
practicing what she was gonna say so
that she doesn't need editing
that's a that's a better skill that will
serve her forever
because you guys will have to whether
whether YouTube is still around in 30
years or not the skill set of
communicating to a camera is never going
to go away
when we're all Holograms and beaming
into uh Michael's living room
having a session it's still talking a
bunch of cameras right and so that's a
skill set that's worth learning instead
of if you're interested and you're
passionate about it cool yes go for it
but if if it's just a strategic move
like hey I think this is really going to
help my channel then I would default to
making you better instead of making the
production quality better quality of
thought definitely definitely definitely
um
yeah you can go prove it wrong like go
go try a second camera and see and show
that the retention is better
um but every time I've seen production
quality go up
you hope like this is it now I'm big
time you know now I'm ready to go and
then like oh it's the same
if you want to see this full video as
well as trained live with me twice a
month to blow up your brand join the
brand Linux training program there's a
link to join right there next to me
continue to believe I'll see you there